Haha, Loser mit deinem Kackbord. Halt, stopp, ich fühle mich gemobbt, mein Niveau, dein Niveau, hallo, Abstand. Halt, stopp, ich fühle mich gemobbt, mein Niveau, dein Niveau, hallo, Abstand. Halt, stopp, ich fühle mich gemobbt, mein Niveau, dein Niveau, hallo, Abstand. Wow, stark! Mal! Ah, fantastisch. Stark, stark. Ah, fantastisch. Die schönste Version, ich werde auf jeden Fall in meinem Leben niemals Johannes und Philien mobben, niemals. Mach ich nicht, du schaust mich schon so an, mob rein, mach, wir haben so viele Charakterste. Ich will dich mit ganz anderen Sachen mobben, du hast hier gerade eine Packung Pommebären hier reingemampft, jetzt leckt er seine Fettfinger ab, wurschtelt hier rum.
Man hört die Pombären aus, die sprechen. Ich habe noch diese Pombärleiber noch zwischen meinen Zähnen hängen, schön zwischen den Zähnen, die kenne ich die gesamte Folge. Blutigen Pombärenleiber schreien. Die gesamte Folge werde ich die noch rausziehen aus meinen kleinen Geheimtaschen, die ich in meinem Mund versteckt habe. Wer das da ist, der sich so diebisch freut über die toten Bärchen in seinem Mund ist, Florentin Will, vielen Dank fürs erneute Erscheinen. Und wer hier mir gegenüber noch nie Spaß hat in seinem Leben, das ist Stefan Tietze, schön, dass ihr da seid zur neuen Ausgabe von das Podcast UFO. Ihr habt gehört das Intro von Johannes und Filine oder Filin, vielen, vielen Dank. Ich hoffe, ihr werdet niemals gemobbt in eurem Leben, auch wenn ihr einige Charakterschwächen habt, aber muss man ja nicht drauf eingehen. Oh, glaubst du, man wird wegen Charakterschwächen gemobbt? Das glaube ich nicht. Na ja. Oh, erstmal Hände reiben. Für diese Antwort muss man sich erstmal die Hände reiben. Entschuldigung, wie heißen die, die Grashüpfer, die Sonnenanbeter. Sonnenanbeterinnen. Die Mücken, die auch immer so, lecker Blut!
Fliegen, wenn man so Close-up zum Fliegen sieht. Lecker
Blut. Aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, während du
jetzt was trinkst, ich bin sehr stolz
auf uns, dass wir nicht zu den Podcaster
gehören, die regelmäßig
snacken während der Folge. Nein, wir
machen das zwischen Aufnahmen, Voraufnahmen,
danach, davor. Ich wollte
gerade fragen, ob es völlig okay wäre, wenn ich in Zukunft vielleicht die Packung Pommeern während der Folge esse und nicht davor. Du, weil davor... Das enttäuscht mich. Nein, aber es ist ein gewisser Stress. Guck mal, Pommeern ist es für mich der einzige Moment am Tag, wo ich wirklich glücklich sein kann, wo ich wirklich mal in mich schöne Dinge... Dann ist sie doch an jedem anderen Punkt des Tages, als wenn die Podcast-Folge aufmacht. Ich brauche die Energie, ich brauche die Kraft in meinen Adern, ich brauche das Salz auf meinen Lippen, um durch so eine Folge zu kommen, Stefan. Und da denke ich mir natürlich, es ist natürlich auch was anderes, wenn ich mir das hier kurz vor Aufnahmenbeginn da reinhämmer, würde ich in die Schweine-Luke reinstopfen, wie nichts Gutes, als wenn ich das vielleicht während der Folge. Nichts Gutes. Nee, das ist dann auch so, guck mal, jetzt bin ich nämlich auf Turbo, jetzt bin ich auf volle Power. Ja, ich wünschte, ich könnte 80 Prozent von dem bekommen. Und ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich mit dieser Energieüber weiterkommen sage. Das merke ich. Ansonsten, wenn ich über die komplette Folge vielleicht so jede Minute einen Pompär, und ich glaube, der Zuschauer würde das nicht so stark mitbekommen, dass ich da knusper, dann könnte ich das so ein bisschen breiter streuen. Ich glaube, es kommt nicht gut an. Und ich selber denke auch, als Zuhörer denke ich mir immer, boah, macht das doch was anders, weil man fühlt sich so ein bisschen egal. Also als wäre es den Leuten, die das dann aufnehmen, egal. Als würden sie es nicht so ernst nehmen. Du siehst ja auch nicht Mick Jagger auf der Bühne, ähm, kurz so Schnüre, diese Hitchlers Schnüre, wie heissen die?
Ja, ja, Schnürlis.
Die Schnürlis, die es bei Lidl an der Kasse gibt.
Die er sich so reichen lässt von so einer Stagehand, so, ja, und dann so die Erdbeerschnürlis.
Oder die sauren Spinnenbeine von Hitchler.
Ja, aber nicht, dass die zwischen Songs irgendwie so eine Lakritzschnecke aufrollen.
Genau, ja, oder dass so ein Autor bei so einer Lesung dann irgendwie so vorliest und dann irgendwie so schön Pommels dann einfach nochmal so reingeht. Habe ich es noch nicht gesehen. So diese kleinen Ufos. Ich habe auch nicht gesehen, dass bei der NASA jemand in der Kommandozentrale sitzt und erstmal schön reingreift in die Ahoi-Brause. Aber Brad Pitt sneckt ständig in Filmen und ist der coolste Typ. Warum? Ist der coolste Typ, weil er ein cooler Typ ist und Rusty in der Oceans-Reihe snackt ständig und Brad Pitt musste irgendwie so 14 Shrimp-Gläser essen für diese eine Szene, wo Julia Roberts die Treppe runtergeht und ja, kritisches Frauenbild in Oceans Eleven müssen wir jetzt gar nicht den Sack aufmachen. Stefan, du machst den auf. Du machst den auf. Ja, man raubt Geld und die Frau und ist das wirklich... Wirklich, mit Anlauf gegen die Wand. Oh nein, nein, ich meine doch jetzt... Nein, das muss doch jetzt gar nicht sein. Der Sack ist da, aber lass ihn auf Zoom. Aber warum musst du denn ansprechen? Ja, weil es in der Szene verhandelt wird. Aber dann geht ja jetzt nichts drum. Ja, es gibt ja den Text. Es gibt ja den Text. Ja, aber wofür stehen die Shrimps? Wie snacken, während sie da die Frau anglotzen? Die Oralbredigung. Ja, aber das gehört doch dazu, das ist doch alles Teil, Kontext. Das ist ja ein problematisches Frauenbild. Aber Shrimps sind lecker. Stell dir vor, wir hätten beide hier so ein Glas Shrimps. Oh, und das könnte man auch gut snacken zum Podcast, weil das nicht cruncht. Oder ein Pudding. Also es gibt ja wirklich so viele Dinge, die man essen kann, ohne dass es jemand merkt. Oder, pass mal auf, liebe Community da draußen, wir machen uns mal folgendes. Wir werden in den nächsten fünf Folgen etwas verzehren während einer Folge. Wir sagen nicht was, wir sagen nicht welche Folge. Es liegt an euch herauszuhören, allein am Klang. Und für die Videopodcasts willst du das Video lösen. Ja, vielleicht, nee, wir müssen auch an den Clubmitgliedern, auch an denen vorbei essen, indem wir auch da visuell uns die Hand vor den Mund halten. Und wir müssen natürlich jetzt schon vorarbeiten. Also das ist ja wie im Unterricht, wo du ja irgendwie Musik gehört hast im Unterricht, indem du das Kabel durch deinen Ärmel gefädelt hast. Oh mein Gott, warum sollte man den Kopfhörer? Gott, wie uncool. Und dann hast du deinen Kopf aufgestemmt auf deiner Hand. Damit das aber klappt, musst du die Woche davor schon jeden Tag deinen Kopf aufgestützt haben, damit der Lehrer sich dran gewöhnt. Genauso müssen wir jetzt immer so reden, immer so reden, damit wir, wenn wir dann irgendwie das Raclette oder Pizza, ich sag nicht, was wir essen werden, Baumkuchen vielleicht, Lebkuchen, weiss ich nicht. Ihr müsst erraten, in welcher Folge wir was essen. Ab jetzt!
Warum hast du ehemals Musik gehört im Unterricht?
Ich habe mich das tatsächlich nicht getraut. Ich habe das nie gemacht.
War das ein Trend bei euch?
Es war ein Kumpel von mir, letzte Reihe.
Stefan Natzel.
Ich werde hier niemanden snitchen, Stefan. Vergiss es.
Snitch.
Vergiss es. Okay, okay. Und du glaubst, dass das jetzt irgendwie 446-folgige Sting-Operation war, dass du über zehn Jahre hinweg mich hier weich kochst, dass ich jetzt den Namen se... Frau Obermeier hat damit nichts zu tun. Wer lauscht da an der Tür? Ich hab Füsse gesehen unten durch die Tür. Albatross. Was heißt Albatross? Was? Ich habe das tatsächlich nie gemacht, aber wir hatten, es war in der Schule immer so einzig, damals war ja ein Handy eben noch was grosses. Im Sinne von gross. Im Sinne von riesig Aktenkoffer, grosse Handys hatten wir damals in den 90ern, 2000er. Und das hatte nicht jeder.
Und das war natürlich dann immer cool, weil du kannst dann schön Helge Schneider hören, wer im Latein oder nicht.
Ja, aber das ist so uncool. Alles dann ist so fucking uncool.
Gorillaz.
Oh, mochte ich sehr.
Hat man gehört, ja, Gorillaz.
Die haben zwei Songs, die gut sind, und der Rest ist ...
Ach na ja.
T-R-A-S-H.
Das ist eine neue ...
Tres?
Tres und ... Tres? Tres?
Wenn man cool sein will, muss man Dinge buchstabieren.
Mhm.
Und dann ist man Leuten immer einen Schritt voraus.
Das ist ein einfacher Trick.
Ah.
Ich finde das Ganze irgendwie ein bisschen L-A-T-M-E.
Latne?
Nee, L-A-T-N-I. Lettne? Das ist Lettisch. Latne? Latne. Latne. Das sind nämlich die richtig coolen, die das nämlich lame, langweilig, Latne. Latne. Latne. Das sind nämlich die richtig coolen, die es auf Lettisch buchstabieren können.
Wir haben gesehen, der Einfluss der englischen Sprache hat, glaube ich, Überhand genommen in der deutschen Sprache.
Wir haben viele Anglizismen, englische Begriffe. Jetzt mal an dich die Prognosefrage. Diesmal am Anfang der Folge. Welche Sprache wird als nächstes grossen Einfluss auf unsere Sprache haben?
Ist es Chinesisch, ist es Portugiesisch, Spanisch, Französisch? Was glaubst du, was ist die nächste kulturelle Grossmacht in unserer Welt? Moment, das sind zwei Fragen. Snackbear, das sind zwei Fragen. Man hört, dass du snacken wirst. Man hört das überhaupt nicht. Das ist überstimmende, übertöntende Geräusch. Es ist lauter als meine Stimme. Ich kenne mich, oh, warte, seit 446 Folgen habe ich einen Podcast, okay, ich kenne mich auch mit Audio-Technik. Und seit zwölf Folgen haben wir eine Diskussion, dass wir zu leise sind. Ich meine, wie gut kennst du dich aus mit fucking Audio und Scheiße. Ich weiß, ich habe wirklich aus meiner Jäschel. Wo wir steht Luf? L.U.S. Light United Focus Service. Federation. Was war die Frage, du hast zwei Fragen gestellt. Welche Grossmacht wird uns überschwappen? Nein, du hast gesagt, welche Sprache wird uns übermannen und dann hast du gesagt, welche Grossmacht wird uns übermannen. Also, ganz klar, China, aber Sprache nicht. Es bleibt Englisch. Das wird zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte so sein. Wir als Welt haben uns Englisch durch das Internet. Alle reden Englisch, auch die Chinesen, alle reden Englisch, es macht keinen Sinn, sich auf eine andere Sprache zu einigen, aber kulturell merkt man ja auch schon den Einfluss von Südkorea zum Beispiel. Genau, stopp, du sagst Chinesisch und ich halte dagegen mit Südkorea. Ja, aber das ist schon seit vier Jahren so. Ja, okay, sag mir mal ein südkoreinisches Wort bitte. nicht Gangnam. Okay, Style. Scherzantiz, du bist so klein, du bist so klein. Pseil, Pseil. Wirklich, du passt in meine Brieftasche. Pseil. Ich kann man wirklich, ah, was heißt das? Das ist der Künstler von Gangnam Style. Nein, aber du kennst kein Wort. Ich glaube, wir werden die Koreanismen mit in unserer Sprache haben und irgendwann gewisse Koreanismen benutzen, wenn nämlich koreanische Superstars wie zum Beispiel BTS überhand nehmen, ja, ich glaube schon, ich glaube schon. Ja, ja, ich war neulich richtig toll, hier in Hamburg war ich ganz toll südkoreanisch essen, Korean Fried Chicken kann ich nur empfehlen, wahnsinnig lecker und die Vorspeise, die war fucking lecker. Und dann wollte ich sie in Köln auch bestellen und ich wusste nicht mehr, wie sie heisst und es war so schwierig herauszufinden. Und es auch nach wie vor, ich weiss nicht, jetzt weiss nicht, wie es heisst, aber man kann es nicht buchstabieren, Teokbocki, Teokbocki, Teokbocki, mit zwei Tee am Anfang. Wow, schau mal, das macht es einem nicht leicht. Der Einstieg ist noch schwierig.T-E-O-K-B-O-K-K-I. Und das Ganze ist was auch immer. Es ist eine eher flüssige, also es ist eine Suppe mit Reiskuchenstücken, die aussehen wie so dicke Nudeln reingeschnitten, haben auch so eine Nudelkonsistenz, aber es ist Reiskuchen, es ist eine rote Suppe, aber es ist kein Tomaten drin, es ist so ein scharfes, was auch immer. Dann noch so Wirsing, so hat dann diesen geilen Kimchi-Geschmack und ist so sehr scharf, super lecker und dann noch oben drauf Käse. Boah, ach geil. Da ist wirklich mehr Gericht. Mein Tipp, mein Tipp, bestellt euch oder geht Korean-Fried-Chicken-Gest und als Vorspeise Teokboki mit Cheese. Ich habe südkoreanische Restaurants auch immer sehr genossen. Ich weiß noch, dass wir am Anfang Tee getrunken haben. Und ich bin ja immer schon... Zwei Tee geschrieben. Genau, Tee, aber ein E. Und ich bin ja eigentlich, möchte gern Tee liebhaber. Ich will immer Tee mögen, am Ende mag ich ihn, aber nicht genug. Ich versuch's aber immer wieder. Du weißt, dass es nicht nur eine Teesorte gibt. weiss, ich probiere auch durch, aber irgendwie bleibe ich nicht hängen. Und da habe ich einen richtig leckeren Tee getrunken. Und ich habe wirklich danach verzweifelt versucht, rauszufinden, was das war. Ich habe mir auf der Internetseite die Speisekarte angeguckt. Ich habe es nicht gefunden. Keine Ahnung, ich würde gerne in den Tee reinkommen, aber es geht nicht. Ich möchte dir einen Tee empfehlen. Und ich glaube, das ist absolut beste, ist super gesund und macht wach und ist unglaublich lecker und die Konsistenz ist auch geil. Olong, Milky Olong, das ist so richtig, der ist so cremig, hat so einen sahnigen Einschlag, macht das so richtig dickflüssiges, so richtig unglaublich lecker. Moment, mit sahnigem Einschlag meinst du, du kippst noch Sahne rein? Nein, Milky Olong. Ach, mit, mit Milch? Nein, man nennt es so, diese Sorte. Das ist eine spezielle O-Long-Sorte. Oh, die kenne ich nicht, O-Long habe ich schon mal gehört. Milky O-Long, darauf musst du achten, das holst du dir. Das ist unglaublich lecker, aber ich habe den Fehler gemacht, dass ich abends sehr viel getrunken habe davon und wusste nicht, dass es Koffein beinhaltet oder Tein. Und dann war ich so ein bisschen wach. Das Problem ist, ich war einmal in so einem Tee-Kontor, wo wirklich so ganz viele tausende verschiedene Tee sind, finde ich immer geil. Da kommen die Schiffe, liegen direkt am Kontor. Was ist ein Kontor? Es ist eine Sammelstelle für unterschiedliche Waren. It's giving Lübeck. It's giving Hanse. Genau. It's giving Sp Hafenstädte. It's giving Spices. Handel. So, da hat der Verbraucher damit eigentlich nichts zu tun. Lecker, Schokolade, Seide, ja, wirklich Menschenhandel, so richtig tolle Sachen. Und da habe ich damals, ich weiß noch, da habe ich mir so ein paar Klassiker, irgendwie so Grüntee, Jasmin, so bla bla. Und dann habe ich auch mal gesagt, haben Sie ja nicht was ...
Was trinken Sie privat?
Was so richtig für die Teeliebhaber ist.
Weil ich bin noch keiner,
aber ich will mal wissen, wo ich sein kann eines Tages.
Mal so ein Ausblick, dass man weiß,
oh krass, da könnte ich eines Tages sein.
Und dann habe ich bekommen, russischer Rauchtee.
Und das war wirklich, das war so ein Luftballon, der war komplett gefüllt mit Rauch, einfach. Das war wirklich wie so ein, also wie so ein, es war kein Luftballon, es war so ein Tee. Ist in dem Luftballon ein Teebeutel mit Rauch gewesen? Es war einfach, nein, das ist Quatsch, es war ein ganz normaler Tee und der schmeckt wie ein Tennisball. Also es ist wirklich wie wenn du, du kennst ja Tennis-Spieler wahrscheinlich, genau, wenn du die Tennisdose aufmachst, dann hast du und genau so schmeckt der russische Rauch. Ich weiss nicht Rauch wovon, ob da Tennisbälle verbrannt werden. Oh mein Gott. Und es schmeckt so komisch, weil du denkst dir, ja ich muss das jetzt mögen, ich muss das mögen, aber es schmeckt halt einfach nach Tennisball. Und es ist so komisch und ich will es mögen, aber irgendwie will es nicht in mein System rein, es wird nicht abgespeichert. Und ich habe wirklich jetzt immer, wenn ich meine Teeschublade aufmache, habe ich immer diesen Packen russischer Rauchteer, wo mit Kugelschreiber das draufgeschrieben wurde, weil es da keine Etiketten gibt. Nein, haben die nicht. Aber Kontor, hast du ja keine Etiketten. Das kommt direkt aus dem Sack, direkt aus Russland. Du hast keine Lampen, die haben fucking Kerzen da rumgeschrieben. Genau, ja. Das ist ein Kontor. Und immer lacht mich das an, ich denke mir, ich will es mögen, aber irgendwie ist es nicht meins. Finde ich ganz, ganz toll. Kannst du mir mal mitbringen? Dann kann ich den mal auftrinken. Ja, wir können ja vielleicht in der nächsten Folge mal einen Tee trinken. Ich bring O-Long-Tee mit und du bringst deinen schwedischen Rauchtee. Machen wir eh nicht. Aber was ich jetzt auch ... Warum sind wir so? Aber ich bin sehr leicht zu beeinflussen, weil ich mag Leute, die Dinge mögen. Und letztens habe ich gesehen Matthew McConaughey, der in einem relativ viralen Video seinen Kokain genommen hat.
Und seitdem ist mein Leben komplett anders.
Also es ist wirklich anders.
Oh nee, der hat beschrieben sein Rezept für einen Thunfischsalat.
Und der hat wirklich...
Also ich bin auch sehr beeindruckt von guten, coolen Dingen.
Nee, aber das ist ein krasses Rezept.
Da ist Mais drin, Mayo, Wasabi, Erbsen, Chips, Apfelstücke, Zitronensaft, richtig geile Sachen mit drin. Mais weg. Ich liebe Mais. Das gesamte Konstrukt, alles was damit zusammenhängt, Mais, und ich meine auch Popcorn, ja, weg mit Mais, weg mit Mais. Was? Mag ich nicht, mag ich nicht, mag ich nicht. Polenta? Weiss ich nicht mehr. Nee, und das habe ich jetzt auch ein paar Mal gemacht. Und natürlich ist auch Gurken, klar, reingeschnitten. Und das ist schon richtig geil. Zwiebeln natürlich. Und da will ich jetzt auch so richtig. Weil ich finde es geil, was man wo anfängt, wo jemand anders schon perfektioniert hat. Das ist sein Rezept, Matthew McConaughey, und der hat es perfektioniert. Und da setze ich an und ich will es jetzt weiterbilden. Ich will die Fackel aufnehmen und jetzt weiter gucken, was kann man noch in so einen Thunfischsalat reintun, was kann weg, die Chips kommen die ganz am Schluss erst rein, damit es super crunchy ist, sind die schon mit drin, damit du ein bisschen mehr so Kautextur drin hast. Ich will das jetzt wirklich perfektionieren, um in 20 Jahren hier mein Thunfisch-Rezept zu präsentieren, um es dann wieder weiterzugeben in die nächste Seite. Das ist richtig lecker. Okay, dann haben wir ein paar Tipps. Also wir haben den Matthew McConaughey Thunfisch-Salat, wir haben Teokboki, wir haben Melki-Olong und russischen Rauchtee. Guck mal, da seid ihr doch versorgt. Da haben wir euch einen schönen Geschenkkorb zusammengeschnürt.
Genau, das ist der Pufo Geschenkkorb, schenkt es doch euren Liebsten ab jetzt auf patreon.com.
Ihr müsst mit dem Tunischen ein bisschen aufpassen, weil da müsst ihr natürlich gucken mit dem Verfallsdatum und alles und so und so.
Aber es gibt manche Gerichte, die sind unfair, weil einfach extrem viel Kalorien drin sind.
Ja, fett.
Und ich finde, man sollte das auch sagen.
Also wenn Leute, ich glaube die Theorie habe ich schon mal geäußert, wenn man irgendwo eingeladen ist und alle bringen was zu essen mit, sollte man sagen, ganz kurz, das hat wirklich 9000 Kalorien. Ja, das wäre meine Frage, aber weil es gibt manchmal so, ich meine jetzt nicht professionelle, industrielle Sachen, du gehst in Edeka, kaufst dir ein, ich weiß nicht, fertiges Gericht und dann ist da hinten so professionell dann diese Nährstoffliste drauf, wo dann, sondern es gibt manchmal auch so, keine Ahnung, da hat so ein lokaler Kölner Patisseriebetrieb, hat irgendwas gebacken und dann so handschriftlich so fast, also nicht, aber es ist so kopiert diese Kalorienliste draufgefallen. Und da habe ich mich gefragt,
okay, 1143
Kalorien, was
genau, wie kommt denn da diese Zahl?
Ja, das ist spannend. Ich glaube, das wird ja
tatsächlich verbrannt. Und dann wird
gemessen, wie viel, also wenn
so mal Labor professionell. Wie wird das gemacht?
Ich glaube, das wird wirklich verbrannt, auf eine Art,
also jetzt verbrennen, stellen wir uns
immer eine Flamme vor, aber das ist ja irgendwie so eine Reaktion mit Sauerstoff und so. Die Definition vom Wort. Gedöns, gedöns, Worte, Worte, Worte. Gedöns, gedöns, gedöns. Und dann am Ende messen die, wie viel Energie da rausgekommen ist am Ende. Und das ist natürlich dann immer so. Aber zum Beispiel Kartoffelbrei. Ich dachte mir auch mal, wäre doch geil, mal einen guten Kartoffelbrei zu können. und dann schaue ich nach Rezepte und dann heisst es, ja, also für den klassischen, wirklich so französischen Kartoffelbrei nimmt man so gleiche Menge Kartoffeln und Butter.
Bitte was? Ich glaube, du kannst bei chefkoch.de die besten, das ist ja der alte Trick, man gibt ein Kartoffelpüree oder Kartoffelbrei, gibt dann ein Sortieren nach den besten Bewertungen. Und ich glaube, du kannst wirklich, du gehst von oben runter und es wird weniger Butter. Du sortierst auch nach Kalorien, wenn du nach Sternen sortierst. Die besten Rezepte haben die krasseste Menge Butter. Und da denke ich mir, wenn du jetzt bei so einer Familienfeier eingeladen wirst und, ah, ich habe mein Kartoffelpüree dabei, oh lecker, wow, das schmeckt ja richtig gut, hast du richtig toll gekocht, finde ich, sollte man gesetztlich dazu verpflichtet sein und sagen, nee, das ist 50% Butter, Fett, 50% fett, weil irgendwie Tante Rita mit ihrem Nudelsalat, mit irgendwie ein paar Tomatenstücken und Gurkenstücken drin, die wird links liegen gelassen, aber die hat einfach einen Bruchteil der Kalorien. Fettarme Sachen oder fettarme Milch. Genau, ich habe extra die fettarme Alpro
Sahne da reingetragen und sowas.
Und da finde ich, geht es auch
in Richtung Betrug. Dass wenn du
zu viele Kalorien hast, ist es Betrug.
Weil du bist kein guter Koch, du nutzt einfach
nur doppelt so viel Öl oder Butter oder was auch
immer. Das finde ich, da sollte man
dazu verpflichtet sein. Ich bin jetzt,
habe das Jahr eingeläutet
des Mealpreps und
Overnight Oats.
Ich weiß, das klingt jetzt mal ein bisschen lame und langweilig.
Ja, klingt vor allem nach 2019.
Ja, ich bin jetzt
in 2019 angekommen,
weil ich habe Bock,
einmal die Woche mache ich was, bereite ich was vor,
koche was, und dann kommen das in schöne
Gläser, die kann man so geil luftdicht verschliessen und dann habe ich die ganze Woche kaltes Essen, weil ich mir dann wahrscheinlich nicht mehr warm habe, weil ich zu faul bin. Ja, ja, okay. Aber wenn es lecker ist, warum nicht? Ja, ja. Aber dann koche ich mehr. Also okay, einmal mehr und dann weniger, ja. Ja, und dann macht man mehr, es ist glaube ich, lass es wirklich. Dann weißt du, was drin ist. Aber es ist wirklich erschreckend. Ich habe ja auch das große Fan, bin ich von Geständnis eines Küchenchefs, von Anthony Baudin. Ganz, ganz tolles Buch. Und der sagt auch immer, je mehr Butter, desto besser. Das Problem ist, ich habe so wenig Willensstärke. Ich würde wahrscheinlich bei so einem Mealprep einfach schon alles am ersten oder zweiten Tag aufessen. Ich kann kein fertiges Essen rumstehen haben, weil ich denke mir, weil wenn ich dann so acht Tage im Vorhinein denke mir, ah ja gut, er kann jetzt zwei essen, so habe ich immer noch genug. Ich habe einfach die Willensstärke. Alles, was vorhanden ist, wird gegessen und ansonsten müsste ich es wirklich wegsperren oder irgendwie Was sagt das über uns aus? Also rein tiefenpspsychologisch, das geht mir ganz genau so. Keine Disziplin, keine Willensstärke, impulsgetriebene Idioten-Arschlöcher. Was sind wir? Ja, ganz genau. Und ich glaube, wir sind sehr gut darin, zu verargumentieren, warum das jetzt trotzdem geht. Ja, so eigenes Rationalisieren. Ich glaube, ich habe in meinem Kopf so einen Christian Solmich, Rechtsanwalt und Partner bei WBS Legal in Köln,
so wirklich so einen Profi-Anwalt, der sagt, na ja, technisch gesehen haben wir gesagt, wir machen eine Diät, und laut Gesetz haben wir unseren Kalorienhaushalt schon erreicht. Aber hier, wenn Sie mal schauen bei Paragraph 8 Absatz 4 Nummer 3, da steht, dass tatsächlich, wenn Sie an diesem Tag schon Ihr Zimmer aufgeräumt haben und den Müll rausgebracht haben, dann haben Sie sicher eine Belohnung verdient. Und dann hast du ständig diesen Anwalt an deiner Seite, der sagt, Moment Einspruch, ja mein Mandant hat zwar alle fünf Milchschnitten gegessen, aber dafür... Die hätte er eh gegessen. Die hätte er eh gegessen, weil er hat sich nämlich, er hat versprochen, dass er am nächsten Tag keine Milchschnitten isst. Deswegen hat er eigentlich diese fünf Milchschnitten an zwei Tagen gegessen. Oder vielleicht, sehr geehrte Geschworene, sogar an drei Tagen, denn der dritte Tag ist ein Sonntag, da hätte er gar keine neuen Milch-Schnitten kaufen können. Also hat er nicht fünf Milch-Schnitten an einem Tag gegessen, sondern fünf durch drei, ich glaube, das können die Anwesenden hier selber ausrechnen. Vielen Dank, I rest my case. Keine weiteren Fragen. So. Ja, und er hat doch heute die Treppe benutzt, anstatt die Rolltreppe. Genau, ja. So geht es mir nämlich immer, wenn ich Sport, wenn es um Sport geht, mach Sport, nein. Ja, ich habe jetzt hier eine Packung, also ich habe die Packung Pombernen, ich meine, vor allem da ist ja das meiste Luft eigentlich und wenn du den Pombernen anschaust, der hat ein Loch im Bauch, der hat ein leckeres Gesicht, das ist ja eh nicht alles, das habe ich mir immer bei, ich habe mir früher oft so tiefkühl Chicken Wings gekauft und im Ofen gemacht und ich dachte immer, naja, da steht jetzt da drauf 750 Gramm.
Das meiste verbrennt aber im Ofen. Aber das meiste ist ja Knochen. Also da sind ja die Knochen schon drin bei 750 Gramm. Ich esse ja nicht 750 Gramm Chicken Wings, ich lasse ja die Knochen übrig. Also von daher, worüber reden wir überhaupt? Am I right? Habe ich recht? Und dann ist es einfach kein Thema mehr. Ja, aber ich verstehe es genau. Ich verstehe es absolut genau und da hat man diesen Anwalt in sich, der innere Schweinehund, der innere Christian Solmecke. Ja, den muss man überwinden? Nee, der innere Schweinehund. Nee, du musst doch, ja, du, klar. Man sagt doch, überwinde den, der innere Schweinehund ist sein Gegner. Du musst deinen inneren Solmecke überwinden. Das ist ja dein Gegner. Nee, das ist eben mein Freund, ich hab zu starke Freunde. Ich weiß, der Schweinehund ist ja auch dein Freund, der sagt, er liegt auf der fucking Couch und ist seine Milch. Der Schweinehund muss stärker werden, der muss mich ja kriegen, der ist ja der Richter. Denkfehler. Der Schweinehund sagt ja, ist die Milchschnitte. In Freuds Persönlichkeitsmodell ist der Schweinehund ... Über ich, es, es. Moment, was? Also, wer ist der Schweinehund genau? Der Schweinehund ist der, der sagt, liegt auf dem Sofa. Liegt jetzt noch den ganzen Tag auf dem Sofa. Und dein innerer Christian Solmöcke ist ja genau in der gleichen Rolle, nämlich da. Der argumentiert ja für dich, warum es völlig okay ist, dass der Mandant den ganzen Tag auf dem Sofa liegen kann. Also der Schweinehund ist der Täter, der von Solmecke verteidigt wird und mit Argumenten durchgebracht wird, sodass er freikommt. Naja, es ist ein Dreipol-Modell. Bei der Dreifaltigkeit. Du selbst in der Mitte, der Schweinehund und der Solmecke, der boxt sich frei. Also, Freud hatte, ist das ES, das Über-Ich. Und du kommst mit der innere Christian Solmecke, da brauchst du neun Seiten, Fussnote. Du musst ja weiterdenken, du darfst ja nicht bei Freud stehen bleiben. Und dann, sehr originell, du hast den Schweinehund. Wow, den inneren Christian Solmecke überwinden, in K Klammern Schweinehund. Bestseller rum. Spiegelbestseller. Ja, ja. Das war ja Eckart von Hirschhausen. Die Leute haben es verstanden, was er gesagt hat. Weiß nicht, was er gesagt hat. Wieso sagst du wahr? Das war ja Eckart von Hirschhausen. Oh stimmt, wann kommt die Folge raus? Fuck. 7. Januar. Arsch. Da ist er noch. Achso, nicht das. Wann kommt die Folge raus raus? Ach so. Nie, der war im Gefängnis. War der da schon im Gefängnis? Er kommt jetzt jetzt. Wir haben damit nichts zu tun. Steigen wir raus. Okay, wir schneiden sie raus. Aber hast du denn die Rohrbombe? Die habe ich ... ja. Naja, ich habe den Zünder, habe ich jetzt an der anderen Seite angebracht. Ist aber okay. Ich glaube, das passt schon. Ich glaube eh, wenn man das alle Spiegel verkehrt, also diese Anleitung zum Drehdrucken war nicht so ganz klar. Ja, aber da war es jetzt. Wenn man es ja aber alle Spiegel verkehrt war. Ja, aber denk an Kontergan. So, das war auch eine Spiegelung von dem Molekül und dann hat es was ganz anderes. Ah, ich sagte unser Kumpel. Nee, er hat es was ganz anderes ausgedacht. Kontergaren. Nee, überhaupt gar nicht. Ich rede von Breaking Bad Folge 1. Als Verbrecher muss man das gesehen haben. Du hast, was hast du noch für Filme geguckt über den Jahreswechsel? Weil das interessiert mich ja immer doll. Ich rede gerne mit dir über die alten Filme, die du ausgepackt hast. Du hast Da Vinci geguckt, guck nochmal. Ich habe nämlich Harry Potter Folge drei mein Alfonso Cuaron. Ich liebe den Kerl. Alfonso Cuaron hat wirklich den Ball aus dem Park geschossen, wie man sagt. Ich finde den Film fantastisch. Der Treffer versenkt. Der, von dem hätte ich gerne die anderen Filme noch gesehen, in seiner Interpretation. Da reicht mir aber so ein K-I-Ding, kannst du eintippen. Genau. Tipps ein? Tipps ein. Ich habe Herr der Ringe gesehen, jedes Jahr, die Gefährten. Unglaublich, also was mir aufgefallen ist, die Gefährten, wie lange Frodo und Sam noch alleine sind, bevor Mary und Pippin dazukommen. Weil du hast ja am Anfang die Geburtstagsparty von Bilbo, da sind die zu viert. Dann hast du die Szene 111. Geburtstag! So toll, alles toll, alles schön. Dann hast du die Szene in der Kneipe, Unterberg. Nee, nee, nee, noch lange nicht. Dann hast du die in der Kneipe, wo die alle gemeinsam trinken und wo es auch so ein bisschen rosy und so und wo dann auch ein bisschen dargestellt wird, dass Frodo eigentlich schon ein bisschen frischer und jünger denkt als die anderen Hobbits, die ja so, was ausserhalb des Auenlandes passiert, interessiert uns nicht und wir sollten uns, und Frodo denkt ja, fuck, wir müssen, wir brauchen Strafzölle, mehr Strafzölle, Tarife und so, genau. Und da sind ja auch zusammen Frodo, Sam, Mary und Pippin, die vier Freunde, die zusammen feiern. Der Zuschauer denkt, ah, die leben zusammen in diesem Dorf, weil die waren auf der Geburtstagsparty, die sind jetzt in der Kneipe zusammen, kein Problem. So, dann geht aber die Reise los von Frodo und Sam. Sie reisen einen kompletten Tag lang. Sam hat seinen
wenn ich einen Schritt weiter
bin ich so weit weg wie noch nie zuvor
Moment. Lame-ass Moment. Lame-ass Moment.
Dann schlafen sie im Wald, sehen
Waldelben, sehen Elben
im Wald in der Extended Edition, in der Extended Edition,
in der Extended Edition rausgeschnitten.
Aus gutem Grund finde ich gut, dass es rausgeschnitten wurde,
weil es, finde ich, den zu High Fantasy
zu schnell ist. Egal. Jetzt muss ich sagen, habe ich von dem ersten Teil dann noch nie die Extended gesehen. Oh ja, ja. Weil ich habe das Buch gelesen, da trifft er diese Waldelben, ich habe mir so, wie geil ist das denn? Da habe ich den Film noch nie gesehen, krass. Da siehst du, wie Isidro den Ring verliert. Das ist ja etwas, was... Nein, das sieht man auch in der anderen Version. Nein, das sieht man nicht in der anderen Version. Na, okay, wie? Na, sag. Geschöpft Gollum hat tief in die Nebelberge getragen. Aber da wird nicht beschrieben. Es fällt runter. Genau, du erfährst nie genau, wie verliert Isildur eigentlich den Ring. Das erfährst du in Next-End Edition. So, aber jetzt hast du... Wie denn? Das müsst ihr euch schon selber angucken. Okay. Ein Ork-Hinterhalt tötet Isildur und er fällt ins Wasser und dann gleitet ihm der Ring vom Finger anstatt dass der Ring sagt ah cool Orks, das sind ja die Leute von Sauron, dann gehe ich direkt an die, sagt der Ring nee, ich gehe ins Wasser, quasi weg von den Orks, wo man auch denkt, hard to get, willst du gefunden werden, Ring, was ist genau los bei dir?
Ja, ist immer noch ein Ring, ne? Ist immer noch ein fucking Ring.
Ja, aber es wird schon impliziert, dass der einen eigenen Willen hat und so.
Ja, ja.
So, und dann schlafen die im Wald, die laufen schon einen kompletten Tag weiter weg, als Sam je war, und dann kommen erst Mary und Pippin. Wo ich mir denke, die wohnen eine komplette Tagesreise von dem Wohnort von Sam und Frodo entfernt, sind eine Tagesreise gefahren für das Geburtstagsfest, sind eine Tagesreise gefahren für die Kneipe und jetzt finden die die erst zufällig, also das, im Buch ist es ja ganz anders, mal ganz kurz am Rande. Im Buch übernehmen die das noch viel ernster, weil da sagen die, okay, Frodo verlässt das Auenland, was sollen denn die Leute denken?
Und dann erfinden die ein anderes Haus in einem anderen Ort, wo er hinzieht, was er nie tut, aber das ist deren Alibi. Die ziehen um.
Genau, die ziehen um und Mary richtet das schon mal ein und fährt mit dem Karren und du liest es und denkst, das ist mir so scheißegal, Mann. Da waren doch schwarze Reiter, oder nicht? Oder what? Und du so, ja, wir müssen jetzt das einrichten. Ja, fahr du schon mal hin, richte das schon mal ein mit den Vasen. Aber ich krieg das nicht ein, ich sag nur das Klavier, kriegen wir auf den Karren drauf. Das kriegst du auf den Karren drauf, klar. Nein, das sieht jetzt nur so gross aus in der Hobbit-Höhle. Ich hab's hochkant. Wir haben das so doch auch transportiert. Mary, wir haben das doch so auch reingebracht. Ja, wo ist es hergekommen? Aber habe ich schon mal gesagt, das ist von Tante Margret noch der Karren gewesen, der war grösser, der war grösser, der war grösser, aber das war doch auch ein Einspannender. Oder war der nicht grösser? Das war auch ein Einspannender. Der alte Udo, der ist der alte Rappe. Nein, Udo, nein, Margret von Bernd. Ach, Margret war so, und so geht das Seiten um Seiten und du denkst dir, das ist doch das letzte Problem, dass der Held ein Alibi braucht jetzt für seine Verwandten. Als würde Luke Skywalker sagen, ja scheiße, was sage ich jetzt den Leuten, dass ich jetzt weggehe? Pass auf, wir bauen irgendwie so, das ist doch vollkommen egal. Da sind Gott sei Dank alle gestorben. Da sind alle einfach gestorben, weg. Da musste man die nicht mehr belügen. Uncle Owen. Und das ist mir aufgefallen bei diesem Durchgang von The Head of the Ring. Wir sehen uns nächstes Jahr wieder, wenn ich ihn wieder schaue. Cool, und das Spannende an diesen Sachen ist ja, die sind so monumental, riesig und fucking selbstbewusst, dann fallen einem da immer wieder neue Dinge auf.
Ja, das mag ich sehr. Ich habe Dune nochmal geguckt, Liebe beide Teile, liebe ich. Vor allem auch da, ja, das ist nämlich, weil du kein geübter Kehlensänger bist, das ist nämlich das Problem. Und immer wieder mache ich den Fehler. Vor allem, also das kommt ja ursprünglich aus dem Mongolischen, dieses Kehlkopfgesang. Und da gibt es auch coole Videos auf YouTube und für uns hat das natürlich auch diesen, ah, die Steppe, die Härte und so wirklich dieses kriegerische Genghis Khan.
Aber wahrscheinlich sind es ja relativ normale Volkslieder. Das ist ja wirklich irgendwie der Alpenjodel.
Die Gedanken sind frei.
Ja, oder halt irgendwie lebt in der Alte Holzmichel noch auf Mongolisch Schlager.
Wie schauen denn Mongolen Dune?
Genau, das ist kulturell übersetzt. Wie wenn wir jetzt so einen Schuhplattler hören würden oder jodeln. Theo, spann den Wagen an. Das ist halt deine Interpretation jetzt von Bedrohlichen. Okay, verstehe. Es ist so ein Knabenchor. Theo, spann den Wagen an. Vielleicht so ein Kanon.
Kanon, genau.
Wo wir denken, so ein Kinderding ist für die, weil es geht ja kulturell komplett verloren, weil für die das halt vielleicht normal ist.
Das ist wie halt so eine Ziehharmonika, das ist der normales, volkstümliches Instrument, deren Art zu singen, ganz normal.
Nicht Theo, Theo, spann den Wagen an.
Heyo?
Nicht Heyo.
Nee, nicht Theo. Ich dachte Theo. Heyo? Theo ist auch ein Lied, ne? Was ist ein Volkslied? Heyjo. Theo pack die Wagen an, schlag die Wagen an, zieh das Segel hoch hinaus, zieh das Segel hoch. Theo fahr hinaus in die grosse weite Welt, Theo komm zurück und gib mir doch mein Geld. Das ist Theo. Und dann gibt es ja dieses Lied Hänschen klein, ne? Und da habe ich mal drüber nachgedacht. Hänschen klein ging allein in die weite Welt hinein, Stock und Hut steht ihm gut. Ja. Der G-Stock. Hänzchen klein, ist richtig klein.
Dass man dann so aus seinem Aussehen ist schon weird.
Wer singt das denn?
Steht ihm richtig. Steht ihm, also macht einen schlanken Fuss, ne, so einen Hut.
Aber Theo ist sehr, nee, Hänzchen klein.
Vor allem, der Mann heisst Hans.
Ihn Hänzchen zu nennen ist schon eine Entdringung.
Wie ist Hänzchen klein? Und dann noch Hänzchen klein? Also Leute, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, Hut, steht ihm gut, ist gar wohlgemut. Doch die Mutter weinet sehr, hat ja nun kein Hänschen mehr.
Wünschte Glück, sagt ihr Blick, kerne bald.
Die sind so fucking düster, diese alten Lieder, es ist wirklich so düster.
Hui, es geht noch viel düster weiter.
Sieben Jahr, trüb und klar, Hänschen in der Fremde war.
Da besinnt sich das Kind, eilt nach Haus geschwind.
Doch nun ist es kein Hänschen mehr?
Nein, ein grosser Hans ist er, braun gebrannt, Stirn und Hand, wird er wohl erkannt? Dritte Strophe. Eins, zwei, drei, gehen vorbei, wissen nicht, wer das wohl sei, Schwester spricht, welch Gesicht, kennt den Bruder nicht. Kommt daher sein Mütterlein, schaut ihm kaum ins Auge hinein, ruft sie schon, Hans mein Sohn, grüss dich Gott, mein Sohn. Gänsehaut, Gänsehaut, die Mutter erkennt ihn sofort. Es ist Ihr Hänzchen klein. Hans mein Sohn, grüß dich Gott mein Sohn. Braun gebrannt. Ja, es ist so ein bisschen sexualisiert, finde ich. Wirklich? Du meinst, er kommt zurück als Stecher, oder was? Er ist wirklich der krasse Das ist dieser dieser, so ein weirder Kerl, der in der Ecke steht und sagt, steht ihm gut, ne, Stock und Huhn? Ja, wer ist der Erzähler hier? Ja, wer ist das, der Auktoriale? Falls ihr aus der Mongolei kommt, schreibt uns doch gerne mal, wie ihr Dune erlebt habt. Würde mich wirklich mal interessieren, wie dieses Kehlkopfgesang für euch klingt, weil du hast ja immer kulturelle Schwierigkeiten, weil du hast ja, habe ich mal so ein Video gesehen von so einer Begräbniszeremonie aus irgendeinem afrikanischen Land und das klang relativ fröhlich, so und die waren alle super traurig und so, weil die meinten halt, für die klingt das halt so traurig, weil du hast ja gewisse Tonarten oder gewisse Tonstimmungen, die eher traurig klingen, aber das ist ja kulturell nicht immer gleich. Und das finde ich so spannend. Wusstest du, dass wir für Elefanten, dass Elefanten uns süss wahrnehmen? Ja, wirklich? Das ist ja nett. Man hat die Hirnströme mal wieder gemessen. Wir waren mal wieder am Elefanten dran. Wir waren mal wieder am Hirnen. Alle lieben Jahre. Halleluja, allhirhirnen. Es war mal wieder so weit. Schneidet die Köpfe auf. Allhirnen ist das der neue Feiertag? Jedes Jahr zu allhirnen schneiden wir die Schädel auf und gucken dem Elefanten unter die Ohren. Oder den wurden so Elektroden an, wer weiss denn, an den nackten Schädel gekrallt. Wer weiss denn, wie es weitergeht. Jedenfalls hat man erkannt, dass die Emotion ist, süss, wie wir bei kleinen Kätzchen. ja. Das ist also, Elefanten nehmen uns als süss wahr. Jetzt muss man sagen, der Elefant ist ja das grösste Tier. Nimmt der einfach alles als süss wahr? Weil ich finde, der Mensch, jetzt mal ganz, also von dem Kreationisten-Ding weit weg, will ich gar nicht. Süss oder Mensch nicht? Will ich jetzt, aber der Mensch ist schon echt geil in der Mitte, oder? Also wirklich gar nicht jetzt Schöpfer und Kreationismus und Frauen aus der Kirche, so will ich jetzt gar nicht aufmachen. Aber der Mensch ist schon relativ perfekt in der Mitte. Von allen Tieren. Wenn du mal alle Tiere auf eine ... Wären wir in der Mitte? Bei so einer Gegenüberstellung. Du vergisst, dass es eine Milliarde. Ja, Bakterien, scheiße, Bakterien. Nein, nein, Insekten. Fuck, scheiße auf Bakterien. Tiere meine ich, nicht Insekten. Also eine kleine Maus. So, und vor allem, Maus zu Mensch ist Mensch zu Giraffe. So, das ist eine eine Linie. Das ist perfekt. Und ich glaube, wenn du ein Elefant bist, hast du ein relativ tristes Leben, weil du die meisten Tiere als niedlich süss wahrnimmst, kaum was als Gefahr.
Je grösser, bei mir ja auch so, ich finde auch Menschen süss. Ja, absolut. Wenn du mich triffst und auch du küsst mich so auf die Stirn und tätschelst mich so. Ich gebe ja einen Kuss auf die Stirn, ich finde das zu süss. Ja, und ich glaube, als Mensch hast du das grösste Erfahrungserlebnisspektrum, weil du in der Mitte bist und manches ist süss, manches ist furchtentflössend, manches ist beeindruckend gross.
Finde ich perfekt.
Du vergisst die Dinos nicht. Ja, klar, du hast Insekten, aber du hattest auch mal Dinosaurier.
So klingt nach neuesten Erkenntnissen. Okay, jetzt bringen wir alle Steven Spielberg-Filme durcheinander, niemand weiss mehr, was irgendwas zu sagen. Ich habe auch gerne diese neue Doku geschaut, diese Dokuserie auf Netflix, Unsere Ozeane, gesprochen von unserem lieben Freund Barack Obama. Barack Obama. Sorry, aber geht das nicht ein bisschen zu weit? Was? Warum spricht Barack Obama eine Naturdoku? Warum denn nicht? Der Mann war Politiker, der war Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten. Ja? Das ist nicht ein Schauspieler oder einfach irgendein Random Guy, das ist nicht Joey Kelly. Ich habe mich geärgert, dass Angela Merkel nicht die deutsche Variante spricht. Nein, aber das sind keine Entertainment-Leute. Der Mann hat Dinge getan. Oh, ich glaube, dass amerikanische Politiker mehr Entertainer sind als Politiker. Ja, okay, weiß ich nicht. Ich finde das komisch. Ich auch, ich auch. Ich finde das komisch. Er ist ja AD. Ja, aber trotzdem musst du den historisch auch aufarbeiten können. Und da hilft es nicht, wenn der einfach so, ach guck mal, da ist ja Obama in der Sendung. Ich weiß nicht, ich finde das skeptisch. Ich bin da skeptisch. Ich finde, man sollte das trennen. Ja, auch weil natürlich die Rechte das wahrscheinlich dann als unglaubwürdig empfinden sofort und nicht als eine objektive Dokumentation. Wenn der linksgrüne Kerl da ankommt und sagt, unsere Ozeane sind verdreckt, weiß ich nicht. Aber angenommen, du hast da jemanden, der sagt, unsere Ozeane sind voller Geheimnisse. Genau, ja. Ja, was sind die Geheimnisse? Komm. Sind es wirklich Geheimnisse? Eigentlich hat die Welt für dich keine Geheimnisse mehr. Nein, die Antwort liegt auf der Hand. Was sind todbringende Aliens? Todbringende Aliens. Das dachte ich mir schon, ja. Nee, aber weiss ich nicht. Aber wenn es bei der grossen Chartshow Gregor Gysi da sitzen würde, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ich fände es komisch.
Ja, komisch, ja, ich würde mal einschalten. Und ich habe lange nicht mehr die ultimative Chartshow, obwohl es die ultimative ist.
Hat für mich leider das Lied kaputt gemacht. Music is the future.
Supergeiles Lied, megaschönes Lied.
Music was my first love. nah, na, na, Trash, das ist eines der, das ist auf, ich weiss, ich weiss, ich weiss, das Kind ist auch ganz voll gefunden, das ist auf einem Level mit Bohemian Rhapsody.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, In der ganzen Welt. Music was my first love, and it could be my last. Moment, ich finde, in dem Lied passiert einen eine Stelle, die ist so geil, weil was passiert? Er singt, alleine, er endet auf einem Ton und der gleiche Ton wird von der Geige übernommen und es geht ineinander über. Wow, das ist magic! Sag mir einen anderen Song, der genau das macht. So, ich warte! Eine Milliarde! Ja, sag einen, ich warte! Weil das so ein krasses ... Ich warte! Ich warte! Ey, das ist so dramatisch, das geht hoch und runter, die Höhne ... Hör mal auf, sag mal, du bist so auf dem falschen Weg gerade, du bist so auf dem falschen Weg gerade.
Onkels, die lieben dann so die Abba-Songs, die kennen so drei Abba-Songs, alle CDs, die die haben, sind so Kuschelrock, Kuschelrock 950, nein, aber die bekanntesten Songs sind ja Arguably nicht die besten. Die haben nur so Kuschelrock 53, 54 und dann, das sind so die CDs, die die haben, und dann noch DSDS Staffel eins, so dann viel Spaß. Und die hören dann John Mild und sagen, aber mal ist Radio lauter, den höre ich gern zu putzen. Ja und, können alte Leute keine echten Emotionen mehr verspüren, oder was, oder gute Musikleitschätzen, oder was? Nein, diese Art von Menschen, die gerade beschrieben haben, weil die sind alt zu tun. Ey, das ist lächerlich. Du bist so, nee, das ist so ein guter Song. Ach, den Song fand ich auch gut mit acht Jahren. Mit acht Jahren habe ich gesagt, ach geil, das ist genau, was mein achtjähriges Ich berührt. Das ist so schlecht. Du bist so abgehoben, du bist so weit weg von allem anderen, ist das furchtbar. Nee. Du kannst dir keine Schüttung. Das ist der pathetischste Song. Du kannst dir keine, ja und, aber lass doch mal ein bisschen pathetisch auch in dein Herz rein. Ja, aberim Rapsilie macht es ja zumindest noch auf eine geile, künstliche Anspruch, so eine komplexe Art. Der singt den Ton. Und dann spielt die Geige den gleichen Ton. Ja, aber sag mir, okay, bis nächste Woche hast du Zeit, gib mir einen Song, der das macht, das macht niemand. Niemand hat das je gemacht und wird es niemals wieder tun. Zeig mir Kendrick Lamar, der das macht.
Ja, okay, jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Jetzt packt er hier sein Gerät aus.
Nee, ich will dir nur meinen Text vorlesen.
Okay, hast du dir jetzt einen Text geschrieben oder was?
Music was my first love and it will be my last.
Music was the future.
Wunderschön.
Was my first love and will be my last.
Ist das nicht schön?
Nein, ich finde es einfach nur fucking lame. Ist das nicht in zwei Zeilen perfekt zusammengefasst, was dieser Mann mit Musik. Music of the future and music of the past. To live without my music would be impossible to do. In this world of troubles, my music pulls me through. Ja, und dann singt er einen Ton und die Geige übernimmt genau den Ton. Nein. Es ist wirklich geil. Und spielt das Schlagzeug im Takt? Ja. Oh mein Gott, ein Meisterwerk. Michael Bouble hast du noch fertig gemacht, weil er nicht im Takt singt. Und jetzt hast du was dagegen, dass das Schlagzeug im Takt spielt. Stefan, du bist raus. Stefan, nein, du bist raus. Nur gesagt, du lobst die offensichtlich im Dinge. Nee, du bist so bescheuert. Krass, spielen die alle Instrumente den gleichen Ton hat?
Oh, crazy.
Ja, nee, okay, dann zeig, nee, wir müssen jetzt, lassen wir die Fakten sprechen, dieses ungebildete Geblabber will ich mir gar nicht anhören, gib mir doch bis nächste Woche einfach einen Song, der das auch macht.
Den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, ja, und das ist mein Problem ist nämlich, die Chartshow hat das kaputt gemacht, weil das ist der Introsong zu der Chartshow, wird 20 Mal pro Folge gespielt und deswegen, und du hast dich nämlich auch davon kaputt machen lassen, von der Chartshow, dass dieser Song leider ruiniert durch den Dreck gezogen wurde von der Chartshow.
Das hat der Song schon ganz alleine geschafft. Das war die Rubrik, das war die Rubrik, das war die Rubrik.
Stefan macht sich uniebt. Ey, äh, äh, da-ba-da-ba-da-ba-da-ba-da-ba-da-ba-da-ba-ding-a-ding-a-ding-a-ding-a-ding-a-ding. Stefan macht sich unbeliebt. Diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep, diep,iss, dass ich mich da wahrscheinlich jetzt in die Nesseln gesetzt habe,
aber es ist auch okay.
Ich habe mir vorgenommen,
ich spreche dieses Jahr die Wahrheit.
Und wenn ich damit anerke.
Deswegen diese Lügendetektor-Nummer, oder was?
Du willst jetzt das ganze Jahr einen Lügendetektor.
Ja, habe ich einen Lügendetektor
eingebaut in meinen Chip. Hirne wurden aufgeschnitten, Elefanten wurden untersucht, ich auch. Ich habe jetzt einen Chip und das Geräusch werdet ihr schon merken. Wenn ich lüge, dann kommt ein ganz lautes Geräusch. Das hört ihr im Podcast, aber das ist auch physisch hörbar für Leute, die gegenüber von mir stehen. Ah, okay. Ich habe mir was einbauen lassen, um mich selber zu schützen vor meinen eigenen Lügen.
Kannst du mal eine Beispiellüge sagen?
Aber der Ton ist halt super schrill
und schlimm. Hast du schon
mal so viele Rosinen am Stück gegessen, dass
dir schlecht geworden ist? Nein.
Okay.
Interessant.
Ja, ich habe einen Tintus jetzt. Interessant.
Krass.
Das ist spannend. Also ihr werdet
ab jetzt immer wissen, dass Stefan lügt. Genau.
An genau diesem Ton. Genau.
Finde ich richtig gut. Find John Miles
Music einen Scheisssong.
Fuck. So.
Aber ganz kurz mal
an die Lügendetektorindustrie.
Wir schauen uns mal an, ganz kurz, können wir kurz
ein Bild sehen davon? Wir sind Podcast.
Wie, ja, aber können wir kurz ein Bild einblenden? Welche Regie sprichst du gerade an? Entschuldigung. Es gibt niemanden außer uns. Nico. Es gibt keinen Nico. Nico, können wir kurz mal ein Bild einblenden, wie gross waren Lügendetektoren vor 30 Jahren? Einfach hier, einfach hier neben mir. Mit wem redest du? Nico, warte mal. Habt ihr nicht vorliegen? Ja, google einfach. Wer hat das gesagt, dass wir nichts vorliegen haben? Google einfach mal. Wo vorliegen? Einfach mal, einfach 1980 Lügen-Detektor. Irgendeins ist wirklich egal. Was war die Frage? Was war die Gegenfrage? Was war die Gegenfrage? Worauf ist das eine Antwort?
Auf welche Frage ist das eine Antwort?
Ja, mach einfach, blend's ein, neben Stephans Kopf.
Was hat er davor gefragt? Neben Stephans Kopf.
Ich will nur wissen, sag nur, was er sagt.
Warte mal, und jetzt such mal Lügendetektor heute, wie gross der ist.
So, und jetzt macht die beiden Bilder mal nebeneinander.
So, und was seht ihr?
Gleich gross.
Immer noch schreibtisch gross füllende Apparaturen mit Nädeln. Was? Eine Nadel, zwei Nädeln. Das ist ja wirklich Grundlage. Wohingegen, such mal ein Bild von einem Computer. 1980, ey, mach mal diesen Turing-Computer, diesen Alan-Turing-Computer. IBM. Das ist jetzt 50er. So, und jetzt mal einen heutigen Computer, winziger Chip. So, das Meme sieht folgendermassen aus. Alle anderen Geräte sind viel kleiner geworden, wohingegen Lügendetektoren sind immer noch so gross wie vor 30 Jahren. Stimmt nicht, Lügendetektoren sind gross wie eine Faust inzwischen. Aber immer wenn ich, ich habe das doch letztens noch gesehen hier hier so ein paar Streamer mit Montana Black und so haben einen lügendlichen Elektor gemacht. Ja, ja. Und der hatte auch diesen Schreibtischgrossen. Ja, und die sind immer in diesen komischen Räumen, in diesen kalten Verhoorben. Und diese Typen, diese Leute, diese alten KGB-Agenten, die irgendwie so ein, kann man die Buch. Genau, warum kann das nicht jeder, ja, aber damit, ich glaube, die buchen die nur, weil es authentisch dann aussieht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die so wahnsinnig schwierig sind, auszulesen, diese Geräte.
Lügendetektortest buchen, Lügendetektortest für Privat.
Wollen wir das mal machen, eine Folge?
Polygraphentest und Stimm? Oh, lass mal eine Folge machen mit einem Lügendetektor dabei.
Aber was für strange Leute machen das?
Ich habe, hast du nicht auch, wenn du jetzt, wenn ich dir vor, guck mal nichts an gerade, schliess die Augen und ich sag dir, stell dir diesen Mann vor, der neben diesem Lügen geht der Kausch. Du hast doch genau jemanden im Bild, du hast doch genau jemanden im Kopf. Ja, absolut. Beschreib ihn, was trägt er, was ist sein Kleidungsstück, was er trägt? Graue Haare, Hemd. Hemd, Hemd, natürlich hat er Hemd an.
Ich würde auch sagen, Brille, leicht untersetzt, relativ untersetzt, Ledergürtel, Haare nicht mehr auf dem ganzen Kopf.
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Und auch so immer so leicht nach oben gucken, so auf den Bildschirm.
Genau. Und auch immer so semi-interessiert an den Fragen, die gerade gestellt wurden.
Ja, das finde ich auch immer witzig, wenn die fragen so, haben wir schon mal 30 Männer gleichzeitig den Mund ejakuliert? Nein, da ist die Wahrheit. Also völlig egal, wie absurd die Frage ist, einfach so, da ist die Wahrheit. Völlig, völlig abgeschottet von der kompletten Welt. Das ist, wenn du den Job so lange machst, dass dich keine fucking Frage mehr schocken kann. Genau. Der hat mit irgendwelchen Straftätern da gesessen und warum muss es den geben? Der hat Ehen zerbrechen sehen, Freundschaften zerbrechen sehen, alles. Der hat ja alles schon erlebt. 20 Männer in Münder ejakulieren sehen, der hat alles erlebt. Ich frage mich nur, brauchst du den? Oder kann man sich ... Ja, brauchst du. Oder brauchst du den, weil man, jetzt meine Frage, und da sind wir was Grossem auf der Spur, weil man dieses Gerät nicht einfach so kaufen kann. Die haben eine Lizenz und dann kriegst du dieses Ding am Ende überreicht. Ich glaube, du musst es lesen können, das ist wie so ein Erdbeben-Nadelmetter. Ja, okay, schlägt aus, Glückwunsch. Ja, aber wie schlägt's aus? Ja, wow, höher. Das ist doch eine Stunde erklären. Ich weiss nicht, was die Ausbildung von dieser Person ist. Du willst mir sagen, ich kann mir so ein Ding kaufen und kann es nicht lesen. Ich glaube, also mich würde auch vor allem die Ausbildung interessieren von dem Mann. Ausbildung. Vielleicht ist es wie so ein Segelschein, dass du so einen Lügendetektorschein machen musst, dass du der Lügendetektor, du bist ja der Detektor. Ich war beim Segelschein auch so angenervt, weil die erste Sache, was ist überhaupt Wetter? Was ist überhaupt Wetter? Manche so, okay, what, da fangen wir an, lass uns beim Segeln anfangen. Was ist Wasser? Ja, genau. Kann jemand kurz zusammenfassen, was Wasser ist? Und dann verstehe ich, dass das irgendwie so eine Volkshochschulausbildung ist, die irgendwie 14 Wochenenden dauert.
Aber ich glaube, man könnte mir das in fünf Minuten erklären, ich könnte es benutzen. Vor allem ist, also wer genau ist der Lügendetektor? Ist es das Gerät oder der Mensch, der das bedient? Wir fragen den Lügendetektor. Das ist der, der Mensch ist der Lügendetektor. Ich bin der Detektor und das ist mein Gerät. Der ist der Detektor eigentlich. Aber das wäre so geil, wenn das Gerät, wenn man das untersucht und es ist, es macht immer die gleichen Bewegungen in dem Loop. Ah ja. Und eigentlich ist der, das sind so Leute, die wissen es einfach, spüren das. Ja, oder die würfeln das einfach aus innerlich, ja, nein. Vor allem, ich habe hier ein Lügendetektortestpaket, und zwar du zahlst auf luegen-test.de bin ich gerade. Und zwar, du zahlst pro Fragen. Vielleicht liegen die da an dem Ort. Vor allem, ich dachte mir so, du buchst den Typen und du kannst ihm tausend Fragen stellen. So, aber nein, du zahlst. Was glaubst du, kostet ein Test mit fünf bis sieben Fragen? Was, fünf bis sieben Fragen? Du buchst fünf bis sieben und stellst dann fünf. Ah, sehr gut. Fünf bis sieben, warte mal. Hast du bei einem Podcast, den du mit mir aufgenommen hast, den mal vorgestellt, dass du mit einem anderen Podcast sitzt? Nein. Also, was ist drin im Paket? Vorgespräch mit dem Examiner. Gott, im Himmel. Ein Vortest. Dann den Haupttest mit fünf bis sieben eigenen Fragen. Fünf bis sieben. Ich finde es so lustig. Wollte ich noch eine Frage stellen? Vor allem das billigere Paket, da hast du eins bis vier Fragen. Und ich finde es so geil, dass man sagt, nee, ich habe schon fünf, ich muss schon das nächste Paket. Ich glaube, so Pärchen oder so Ehepaare, die holen sich wegen einer, also da ist niemand wegen vier Fragen, wird dann geholt, sondern wegen einer. Hast du mich mit Ute betrogen? Genau, so, es ist fertig. Genau, du wirst wegen einer fucking Frage holen die den. Ihr habt jetzt noch drei Fragen offen. Und währenddessen fliegen schon die Fetzen.
Was ist deine Lieblingsfarbe?
Lieblingsfarbe, gefällt dir mein grünes Kleid?
Nein, okay, gut, alles klar.
Gut zu wissen.
Hast du den Müllhäuschen rausgebracht?
Nein, okay, alles klar, gut, so, jetzt tschüss.
Du hast eins bis vier Fragen
im Treue-Test Basic.
Treue-Test?
Im Treue-Test und fünf bis sieben Fragen
im Treue-Test Standard. Also Haupttest mit fünf bis sieben eigenen Fragen, Haupttest mit zusätzlichen Treue-Test. Im Treue-Test. Und fünf bis sieben Fragen im Treue-Test-Standard. Also Haupttest mit fünf bis sieben eigenen Fragen, Haupttest mit zusätzlichen Treue-Test-Fragen. Was, was, was, was, was, nochmal? Also fast erstens, Vortest. Vor was? Bevor es eigentlich losgeht, das ist ein Vortest. Mit wie vielen Fragen? Ein bis dreißig Fragen. Steht nicht da, einfach mal Testfrage. Dann Haupttest mit fünf bis sieben eigenen Fragen. Jetzt würde ich aber, ich fuchs natürlich meine Hauptfragen im Vortest stellen. Ich glaube, da hat der Examiner aber eine ganz andere Vorstellung. Ich glaube, das geht nicht. So, nach dem Haupttest kommt noch mal ein Haupttest mit zusätzlichen Treue-Testfragen. Was ist das Unterschied zwischen normalen Fragen und Treuetestfragen? Und im Vortest werden auch keine Treuetestfragen gestellt. Aber Premium-Punkte sammelt man nur mit Treuetestfragen. So, und dann mein Lieblingspunkt ist drei bis fünf Testdurchläufe. Du hast drei bis fünf mal ein bis vier Fragen. Also, du hast einmal die Vortestfragen, dann hast du fünf Tests durchlaufen. Das ist ein ganzer Nachbetrag einfach. Und währenddessen der Typ, ja, ich hab betrogen, jetzt kommt endlich zur Frage, Jesus. So, dann gibt's noch eine Abschlussbesprechung, dann ein physiologisches Gutachten. Und dann eine Mittagspause. Und dann eventuell zuzüglich Reisekosten. Du musst die Reisekosten für den Examiner auch übernehmen. Ach, so, was kostet der Spaß? Schätz mal, was kostet der Spaß? Welches Paket? Das ist Standard mit fünf bis sieben Haupttestfragen.
Was kostet das Ganze?
Also wenn man jetzt sagt, für so eine Party oder so, haha, keine Ahnung, holt man sich. 150 Euro. 1.190 Euro. Das ist mehr als ein Geldeimer. Aber wie viel ist die Wahrheit dir wert? Weniger als ein Geldeimer. Ich würde nämlich dann auf Toy-Test Basic gehen mit ein bis vier Fragen für 990 Euro zuzüglich Reisekosten.
Ja, aber kann ich da noch meine Treuetestfragen stellen?
Ähm, du hast einen Haupttest mit zusätzlichen Treuertestfragen und auch hier, und das finde ich interessant, bei dem Standard, also bei dem teuren Paket, hast du drei bis fünf Testdurchläufe, bei dem billigen Paket hast du auch drei bis fünf Testdurchläufe. Aber heisst das, dass ich drei bis fünf mal ein bis vier Fragen stellen kann? Also ich kann ein, doch! Ich glaube, es funktioniert so, erstmal der Vortest. Also, Herr Tietze, ist heute Dienstag ... Ja, das ist eine Lüge.
So.
Was? Jetzt haben wir ...
Was?
Heute ist Dienstag ...
Schatz, ich bin jetzt schon aufs Gelegen.
So, jetzt, wie viele Testdurchläufe möchten Sie?
Im Paket enthalten sind drei bis fünf Testdurchläufe.
Ja, fünf.
Alle fünf?
Alle fünf.
Gut.
Alles da, dann machen wir einen Testdurchlauf. Ist heute Mittwoch … ist heute Mittwoch … Nein! Das ist auch eine Lüge. Was? Ist heute Freitag. Ist das jetzt der dritte dem … Das ist der zweite Testdurchlauf. Warum gucken Sie selber? Entschuldigung, es ist das erste Mal, dass ich es mache. Okay, ja.
Trage ich ein blaues Hemd?
Ja.
Sie haben wieder gelogen. Sie haben noch ein blaues Hemd?
Ja, aber hier steht Lüge.
Ja, ich sehe ja das blaue Hemd.
Haben schon mal 30 Männer in ihren Mund ejakuliert?
Nein.
Das ist die Wahrheit. Okay, ein Testdurch haben wir noch. Das ist dann der erste Durchlauf gewesen. Nee, das ist jetzt der letzte Testdurchlauf. Finden Sie dieses lügende Testdurchlauf-Ding zu teuer? Ja. Das war eine Lüge. Zu billig. Okay, dann, wie viele Fragen? Ein bis vier eigene Fragen ist fantastisch. Ich liebe ein bis vier eigene Fragen. Ich liebe ein bis vier Fragen in drei bis sieben Durchläufen. Und dann sehe ich gerade, es gibt noch Premium mit acht bis zehn Fragen für 1390 Euro. Dieser Mann verdient 200 Euro mehr, indem er einfach zwei weitere Fragen beantworten lässt. Ja, aber wie oft wirst du ein Gebuch für ein Konzept? Es ist so weird. Das muss es doch zu kaufen geben, dieses Gerät, dass da man in der Lampe leuchtet und nicht dieser Seismographen aus den 60er Jahren lesen muss, sondern in Zeiten von GPT oder so, soll doch einfach stehen, Lüge, Wahrheit. Die billigen Dinger kriegst du klar überall hinterhergeschnissen, aber du willst die richtig guten Tests. Ich glaube, vor allem, das Ding ist, glaube ich, das ist ein psychologisches Ding. Ja, glaube ich. Wenn da jemand vor dir sitzt, der dich anguckt mit so einer Expertise, dann bist du auch ganz anders, als wenn du dir bei Amazon für 12 Euro irgendwie so ein Teil kaufst, was du dir in den Finger schnallst. Schnepperst. Schnepperst. So, ich glaube, du brauchst den Examiner. Ich glaube, der Examiner ist ganz essentiell. Und auch der Preis und auch dieses ganze Happening mit diesen ganzen Durchläufen und Test und immer wieder Test und Test und Test.
Das ist, glaube ich, schon relevant.
Ermüdende sieben Durchläufe.
Um dich wirklich in dieses
Mindset des, okay, fuck, das ist jetzt
wirklich hier, this is it.
So, jetzt kommt die Frage. Ich bin da wirklich geneigt,
weil ich finde das mega faszinierend
und ich möchte dem Ganzen mal auf den
Grund gehen eigentlich. Wir müssten nochmal mit einem telefonieren vielleicht. Einfach, ich will wissen, jemand, der so auspackt. Ich glaube, also ich will den Leuten gar nicht zu nahe treten, aber das klingt für mich schon ein bisschen. Du bist in der letzten halben Stunde zu nahe getreten. Für mich klingt das ein bisschen nach Scam. Ja, voll. Also, dass die Leute, klar, das ist auch ein Happening und so cool, so wie Karten legen, muss man auch nicht immer dran glauben, kann auch irgendwie einfach Spaß machen, whatever so. Aber ich glaube, das ist ein ganz, das ist ein Kartell, aber vor Gericht zugelassen. Nee, ist es nicht. Deutschland nicht. In Amerika ja. Echt? Ja, als Beweismittel zugelassen. Ich glaube, dass diese Geräte auch einfach frei verfügbar sind, aber da drückt jemand die Hand drauf, da drückt jemand die Nadel drauf und deswegen gibt es diese Examiner, die das unter sich machen.
Ja, absoluter Scam-Beruf, aber wir bleiben da dran. Aber du kriegst die halt nicht, weil die dürfen ja lügen. Versucht mal eine Woche Wahrheit. Ja, vergiss es. Sagt mal eine Woche komplett die Wahrheit. Ich wünsche euch auf jeden Fall eine schöne Woche. Kommt damit gut durch mit der fucking Wahrheit. Seid mal ehrlich, vor allem zu euch. Untreue. Ich hoffe, ihr sagt die Wahrheit, wenn ihr uns Antworten schickt auf all die Fragen. Kommt ihr aus der Mongolei? Wie geht's mit Dune? Tragen wir Blaushemd. Haben wir was gegessen in dieser Folge? Hättet ihr was dagegen, wenn wir snacken während der Folge? Was sollen wir snacken? Was sind gute Snacks? Was sind eure Vorsätze? Habt ihr gute Rezepte für Thunfischsalat?
Hat eine gewisse Art Idee, in welche Richtung dieses Jahr gehen soll. Also es ist okay, wenn wir während der Lügendetektor-Folge snacken.
Also dass wir einfach da, macht's gut, tschüss, wir heben ab, bis sechs Wochen.
Worst Bird Production it was.